Have you ever wondered how a country can
be hijacked,
how institutions can be subjective,
averted and corrupted and perhaps most
importantly,
how do you identify the moments in which
a democracy after being taken over stops
working?
Their view of those questions have
pervaded global politics,
butts especially they've pervaded Latin
American politics.
I can do that here on my needs.
He has been put in my name [inaudible]
and peanut butter on it.
Yeah.
Put me at Moz.
Okay.
Last few decades,
numerous last and American leaders of
taking control of their countries.
Sometimes they did it through Kuda Taz,
but in many other occasions these
dictators came to power through
democratic means.
That is precisely the case of Nicaraguan
President Daniel or Tayga.
Okay.
Visual policy.
We've already told you about this
political figure,
how he came to power,
how he behaved and how he was
responsible for the huge strikes that
Nicaragua has been going through in 2018
yeah.
Strikes that have been answered with a
heavy hands and which have led to
terrible consequences.
More than 200 people have lost their
lives.
Hundreds have been detained.
Thousands have been injured.
Well,
in this video,
we're going to take a look at another
aspect of the events.
Yes.
This is the story of how a government's
managed to take control of the state and
make the institutions work,
not for the country,
but for itself.
This is the story of how I kinds of
political Matthia took control of
Nicaragua,
so listen up.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's 2006 and Daniel Ortega winds the
Nicaraguan presidential elections after
16 years as the opposition,
the Sandinista leader returns to the
country,
his presidency,
the precedents,
what exactly good.
His first time as president between 1985
and 1990 was frankly terrible.
I'll tell you,
go left and economically and socially.
It shattered country.
It was a company that went through a
warm ended up with a foreign debt six
times bigger than its GDP and suffered
from hyperinflation that are reached the
astronomical figure of 33.547%
by 1987 to give you an idea of the
magnitude of this disaster,
in 1990 the per capita income of
Nicaragua was 55% smaller than the
country he had registered back in 1978
in other words,
compared to Daniel Ortega,
even the kushners would get good grades.
Ortega's economic model.
It was a huge failure.
The expropriations,
the gigantic foreign debt,
the unstoppable money printing and his
obsession with controlling the economy
led Nicaragua into an unsustainable
situation.
Hands,
I mean,
how wouldn't it of with that recipe,
we has the conscious conflict to all of
this financed by the United States.
The country was submerged in a complete
disaster.
Bye,
right?
For those of you who don't know,
the contracts were paramilitary groups
financed by Washington through selling
weapons to Iran.
When this country was in the middle of a
walk with Iraq,
a country that was supposedly close to
Washington in shorts,
lots of nonsense.
So throughout the following decades,
the country only out of one initiative
that was simply to recover from this
hideous mess.
See
this,
the following government,
starting with that a violator tomorrow,
by the way,
the first elected female Latin American
president decided to turn the country's
political and economic approach right
around that is to move from a
centralized economy,
which was organized and directed by the
state to a market.
Got It.
Salvey Nicaragua and free trade zones
were born now as well as the policies do
attract foreign investments,
which along with international
cooperation and especially the growing
remittances from abroad allowed to
Nicaragua to get back on track.
Hold on just a moment because what these
new governments didn't achieve was
putting an end to corruption.
Thus scandal after scans all the feeling
of frustration,
disappointment,
and deceit that all Nicaraguans fells
along with an opposition who was willing
to do almost anything to return to power
fueled Ortega's victory in 2006 here few
s is where the new story begins,
especially because all Tayga wasn't
going to waste as returned to power.
This was his charms.
This was his to dominate in Nicaragua,
in politics,
finances and society,
but to achieve this and above all to
prevent an electoral process from Maria
evicting him from the presidency.
He needed to seize political power with
an armed force and an economic monopoly.
This as the strategy he set in motion
and the steps he took to achieve his
purpose,
sort of listening,
political power,
obviously his strategy,
his first goal was to achieve political
hegemony and social control by any means
necessary.
This was very clear to Ortega from the
beginning and he launched a double
tactic to achieve it fast by invading
the institutions and centralizing power
and then my limiting and intimidating
the opposition,
something for which fear is usually a
very,
very effective ingredients.
Shortly after arriving Ortega launch day
paramilitary force composed of gang
members.
We're talking about shock and groups
better known in Nicaragua as the
toddlers.
They are feared and the people call them
mobs.
They usually wear tee shirts that speak
of love and peace wear helmets to hide
their faces and move on motorcycles.
They're mostly very violent young
people.
[inaudible] journalists in Managua.
It's objective.
Well,
I would be too intimidated to the
political opposition to frighten those
who disagree with the government and to
try and dismantle the opposition's
demonstrations or concentrations with
violence.
Obviously it isn't an official forests,
but they have the government's
protection and we're going to see how
that works in just a moment.
Say that a para military force has been
set up in Nicaragua that is composed of
gang members,
but sometimes we get on a bus and a para
military member is watching us
[inaudible] Castillo,
Nicaraguan activist,
but of course it doesn't end here.
The next step to achieve total political
control is to take control of the state
institutions as well.
How do you think he did that?
Well
first political decentralization to be
ended,
in this case,
municipal autonomy thus in Nicaragua or
Tayga is political henchmen has managed
to dismiss mayors at will.
Something like,
Hey,
if you've got a political arrive,
I'll just kick him out of the race.
That way you don't need to get rid of
your opponents.
You also win loyal fans who of course
don't want to risk making him out.
Right?
The second step to institutional
takeover was do create ans or legitimize
his own political organizations.
In this case,
the citizen power councils,
these bodies which supposedly involved
community participation in practice have
the objective of creating a parallel
political structure that is recognized
and controlled by the government.
I'm the feds
appoints
and achieve the indefinite permanence of
his party associates in every key state
position.
The electoral power,
the judicial power ends,
the general control that and different
official protests.
I mean that's what those moms is a four
right?
So how about two examples of proving
what Ortega achieved with this strategy?
Well,
check this out.
One ends.
The Nicaraguan Constitution prohibited
the consecutive reelection of the
president,
so I'll tell you go would've completed
his turn and 2001
as Hernandez did in on drs or Tayga and
managed to get to the Constitutional
Chamber of the Supreme Court,
composed mostly of Sandinista
magistrates stupid declared article one
four seven as in applicable,
which is the one that prevented the
presidential consecutive reelection in
exchange.
Yup.
Theme Magistrates positions were insured
for life.
Quite the exchange.
On the other hand,
in 2011 fraud suspicions were so intense
that both the European Union and the
Organization of American States
concluded that they weren't sure if the
results,
you know,
you controlled the electoral power.
Yes it would be,
or tag or,
and he made sure that his followers
could do and undo whatever they wanted.
In fact,
in the following elections,
the 2016 ones,
they didn't even split and the ruling
party took full control of the process.
But hold on a moment.
You might be thinking,
I mean it wasn't there a big scandal
because of the Simon.
Well,
let's say that the president had made
sure that practically every major media
station in the country,
it was controlled by his family of their
associates.
You're taking
a family monopolizes the media in
Nicaragua mobs and the occupation of
institutions and the media,
well,
this is the political side,
but this much more the force monopoly as
cool as much as he holds political
power.
If a dictator,
it doesn't hold the military force,
he's taking a huge risk.
This was very clear to our protagonists.
Say these seconds.
Pillar of this strategy was to take over
the police and to take over the army.
Did he say he took advantage of his
majority in the National Assembly as
soon as he got into power or take your
push to reform that place,
the ability to appoint new faculties of
the National Police and the army of the
republic in his hands.
Then taking advantage of these new
possibilities.
He placed relatives and loyal people
[inaudible] in charge of these
institutions.
For example,
the police aren't directed by his own
father in law Francisco Diaz.
This means you can get the police to
look the other way.
When the mob,
Zach,
since when the opposition strikes,
repression,
well more repression because when the
mafia holds the power,
it's not easy for them to let go.
Well,
we've covered politics and we've covered
force,
but there's still a third element
missing
economic power.
Yeah.
Pillar in the strategy was to achieve
economic power for three reasons.
First to prevent in Nicaragua and
capital from supporting an alternative
seconds to get resources with which to
carry out Ortega's plans and third,
perhaps the most important points to
fill his pockets,
less time.
It corruption has been brutal to such an
extent that the Ortega Morello family a
million as see,
they've taken over the media,
they hold high positions in the states.
They've even taken over oil important
distributions in Nicaragua.
They put themselves in charge of the
investments,
promotion agencies with a plan that we
could describe like this,
wanting to invest in Nicaragua.
Great.
We'll make it happen,
but you have to give me,
I can mention,
you know for the country,
they've also reached agreements with
businessmen apparently by getting
loyalty and envelopes in exchange for
privileges.
Your example,
all of this way of doing things was the
agreements made.
She builds the interracial Yannick
canal,
seemingly unsuccessful projects in which
the government reached an under the
table agreement with [inaudible],
the Chinese developer working on it.
First thea state kept half of the
profits since then with a last minute
change it became 1%
it's
we as Lenny,
the businessmen did some last minute
haggling in short their viewer.
The factors that with political power,
with brute force and with economic
power.
Daniel Ortega became the owner and Lord
of Nicaragua and also a billionaire and
just in case in the last election in
2016 he presented Rosario Marillo.
His wife has vice presidents,
so everything certainly stays in the
family
late.
This is essentially the same thing that
happens in Venezuela.
It is so to speak,
the manual for a dictator.
And the question we can ask ourselves
now is can we really pretends that
Nicaragua or is still a democracy?
Well,
leave your opinion in the comment
section below.
And as always,
if you found this video interesting,
don't forget to subscribe to visual
politic if you haven't already done
that.
And I really hope you enjoyed this
video.
Don't forget to check out.
Reconsider media.
They do a podcast,
they provided the vocals in this
episode.
It's all great stuff.
Also,
as always,
this channel is possible because of
Patriarchy as our patrons on Patrion on
these considered joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
we'll see you in the next video.
[inaudible].